Another parallel communication pattern worth mentioning is called transpose.
For example, you might have a 2D array, such as an image laid out in row-major order.
This means that the elements of the array, or the pixels of the image, are laid out one row at a time.
And I've color-coded the rows here just to show you more clearly what I'm doing.
But you might want to do some processing on the columns of this image.
And so you'd want a lay out like this.
This means you need to do an operation to reorder the elements.
As you can see, I've drawn this as a scatter operation.
So each thread is reading from an adjacent element in the array,
but is writing to someplace scattered in memory, according to the
stride of this row column transpose.
I could also have expressed this as a gather operation, like so.